a world where music does not make an
environmental impact is a world without
music there have never been more ways to
listen to music
streaming is king but physical music
sales of vinyl cds and even cassette
tapes are on the rise
but the creativity of the industry isn't
just confined to the music with artists
bands and labels also doing their bit to
help the environment i think the music
industry has really woken up everyone
wants to sort out the climate emergency
we're all outlets for change musicians
too
[Music]
the first three months of 2021 saw more
than one million final records sold in
the uk a 16 rise from the previous year
vinyl has i think taken us all by
surprise this last year it has gone
beyond the realms that anybody could
have imagined but the amount of plastic
involved in the making packaging and
distribution of albums means the
environmental impact of vinyl can be
high pvc polyvinyl chloride which is a
plastic mainly used to produce lps is
known as a particularly nasty
form of plastic pvc is highly recyclable
and it's built to last
but it can be toxic when eventually
disposed of
when you dispose of it which is usually
either by burning it
or by burying it in the ground
it can it releases toxic chemicals
either into the air or again into the
ground but most people don't get their
music through vinyl cds and cassettes
anymore we now take for granted that you
can
pull from the cloud
an unlimited amount of music
with a basically unlimited catalog
all the time at any point around 487
million people worldwide are subscribed
to a music streaming service and in
terms of plastic use this seems far more
sustainable just look at how much less
plastic is used since most of us started
downloading and streaming music
but that doesn't tell the whole story
digital files take up space and at every
point in the infrastructure of the
internet digital files require energy
there's that storage infrastructure with
server farms and things and then there's
the transmission infrastructure which is
moving the data the streaming music from
those those servers
and then eventually to more kind of
local access networks like your computer
the wireless router which i'm looking up
there to in my office that energy
is dependent on a local electricity grid
when you're streaming an album
you know you are using energy and you
are releasing greenhouse gases since
downloading and streaming became the
most popular way to listen to music
greenhouse gas emissions have gone way
up and these figures are from 2016
streaming usage has massively increased
since then
it's not the individual per play stream
that's environmentally damaging what the
problem is is
aggregate use i guess so you have now
billions of consumers who are taking for
granted the fact that they can pull data
from the cloud which has an energy cost
all the time listening to music isn't
destroying the world and it isn't even
the biggest climate issue in the music
industry when you factor the travel and
plastic use caused by touring but all of
it does have an impact and there are
plenty of bands artists labels and
manufacturers trying to reduce the harm
the industry is doing to the environment
and it's all about changing the world
right and if
anyone's listening they just you know
survive you know what i'm saying you
feel me bro
young talks about environmental issues
in his music powers live shows by
battery and is even one of the un's
young leaders for sustainable
development goals i was talking to like
a really big like music manager you know
and i and there's this guy talking to
him about me and he's like explaining to
this like major industry guy like yo ay
is doing these concerts with renewable
energy and the guy looked at us in our
face and was like oh that's not possible
you can't do a concert i mean powered by
batteries
this was two weeks ago the guy was like
oh excuse me and
eight wise actually he's actually done
800 of them so has it been hard yes it's
been hard but also it was necessary you
know and now i'm here now i'm one of the
17 young leaders now i have the
opportunity
to uh to use music as a vehicle right
because it's a universal language it can
bring
everyone together right so so we can
actually make sustainable regenerative
changes
the hardcore band ithaca are trying to
address the issue too they have reissued
their debut record on recycled vinyl and
say environmentalism is becoming
increasingly important to them kind of
music scenes we come from punk and metal
and rock you know they have a tradition
of being counter-cultural of being
political you know
and we think that one of the most
important
you know political challenges that we
can be involved in as a band is the
climate crisis but for bands of their
size it's hard to make a major impact
the price incentives are skewed in favor
of business as usual in favor of
supporting you know the fossil fuel
industry and the plastics industry and
the petrochemical industry so it is
harder for smaller bands to make the
right decisions or make the decisions
that they would like to make
but that will change if we as a you know
a tiny little uh you know metallic
hardcore band can make the right
decisions why can't the mages and it's
not just bands and artists trying to
make a difference
record label ninja tune say
sustainability is a priority for them we
stopped using
plastic cd dual cases because they have
a high footprint and we switched from
one 180 gram pressings of vinyl in some
cases to now all our pressings are at
140 grams we're looking to
eliminate air freight from our the
shipping cost we don't want a situation
where
saving the planet involves never
listening to music or only listening to
music once in a while or not doing the
things we love it's not about not doing
things it's about choosing the best way
to do these things the answer to all of
these issues is not don't listen to
music
it is a huge part of everyday life and
brings joy for hundreds of millions of
people around the world if you
had no music industry
the world would be a terrible place but
the issue of sustainability in the music
industry speaks to something bigger how
we balance enjoying our lives with being
as sustainable as possible and how we
have a personal responsibility to do
something
even if it seems like it's just
something small
a lot of people wonder should i listen
to music less should i listen in
moderation should i not listen at all
don't not listen at all
the problems that the music industry is
facing in terms of its environmental
impact are industrial choices they are
changeable music is is one of the good
ways to be
living in the world
having said that we need to make this
transition
of decarbonization
urgently quickly just like any other
industry or any other
culture or sector of human activity on
the planet and that's the bottom line
you